and we are live assalamualaikum boys
yo so uh before we get started man what
name would you like us to call you
because when you go on instagram bro you
got three names in the bio
i get this question a lot um call me
whatever you know rakeem is my islamic
name and that's like the name that i
prefer but if you don't want to call me
like shinkansen or william i don't know
i'm the bro we'll go with rakim then
bro quick fire question right off the
bat if you walked into a room and you
saw myself rami and ango who would look
the most muslim to you
all right good so before we go on for a
lot of viewers that don't know who you
are even though you're mashallah and
you're getting tic tac famous nowadays
how would you you know give a quick life
story to a lot of the viewers that don't
know who you are so
um my name is rakeem i reverted on the
8th of march at 4 42 p.m
um this year
yeah man i just mean you know i hope
there's been some struggles with
you know my whole reversion process but
overall alhamdulillah and being a muslim
was one of the best decisions i've ever
made in my life
what do you mean by that
as in
okay
i don't know how else to say you know
like baraka like you just
i don't know how ace to say it but
without saying luck but i don't want to
say luck but things have just been going
my way like before i was a muslim i'm
gonna be honest like
nothing would go my way i mean even to
the smallest things of like
are a topic coming up on a test but ever
since i was muslim
that i've just been blessed it's like
you know everything's been blessings
upon blessings in my life
you know even even the tick tock you
know even the tick tock that's like be
one of the biggest blessings like my
life has changed so much because of it
bro tell me tell me a little bit about
that because when you go to tech of
hamdulillah you have almost a million
followers now and it's assuming it's
been just about a year
so
it was kind of just like
my friend
was like your key and post on tick tock
and obviously
this is when i reverted but i was still
i was still feeling a bit sad i don't
want to say the press because i wasn't
diagnosed with depression but
you know and i know for a fact and now
that was allah testimony 100 i was allah
testing me
um
i was
feeling very sad to the point of
likes i was gonna do something
disgusting
and
you know but i kept on praying even like
i kept on praying i kept on staying on
my beam and you know throughout this
whole period of me being depressed i was
thinking to myself i was like was the
reversion even like did it even matter
like does allah even exist
but i was like screw this i'm still
going to pray i'm still going to be a
muslim because i'm a muslim but as a
muslim i need to pray as a muslim and to
stay on the team
so being so you know it's
i plan out this whole crazy thing of
not existing anymore if you know what
i'm trying to say
i've planned this whole thing of how i'm
going to do it and then
subhanallah
my friend messages me yo rakeem just
posted tick tock
by the way she knows i'm down in the
dumps now she knows i'm just out of it
i post a tick tock i'm like screw this
like this is it's just useless i delete
i delete that
then my friend messages me yo yo yo
check the tick don't check the tick tock
i check here it's got like 10k views
so from then on
all my days it's just been a blessing
man it's just been a blessing
alhamdulillah i love that blessing with
this
[Music]
do you think the tick tock i know
obviously a lot of people benefit from
your tic tocs as influencers as creators
we try to post up beneficial content
that people can relate to but have you
personally benefited yourself from
making content
yeah hundred percent because you know
even down to the smallest things of
people dm'ing me advice
by the way do you understand what i'm
saying
like
even down to the things where it's like
people every day i get people giving me
oh did you know it's sunnah to drink
water three times i mean
and people tagging me in like
islamic videos like watch this thing
you get massive rewards
it's just a blessing man oh you know
being a muslim is blessing man but
yeah
another question bro that i had in mind
before i passed the torch to rami is
when you mentioned that after reverting
almost a year ago maybe 11 or so months
ago that you know it's been a little bit
of a bumpy ride with family and all that
yeah
anything you know you don't have to talk
about anything you're not you know
comfortable sharing your personal stuff
but where's the relationship now did you
fully tell them are they on board are
they not on board what's going on
you know what it is super like this is
the funniest thing
i feel like because i obviously had to
go back for christmas because my uni
holiday right
and my family celebrates christmas
i feel like if you want me to like go
more indefinite i will but i feel like
my parents are low-key accepting it now
because there's no way i feel like
either a lot is backing me like is i
don't know how they haven't found out
about my tics work or my instagram like
i post openly about islam
and i'm posting about you know and my
cousins follow me and everything on my
instagram and my parents somehow don't
know
but obviously
they've been
going definite yeah before you go on in
depth i just want to make a quick if
anyone's wondering including yourself
where angel is he's he's currently in
thailand so he moved uh into a new place
and because of that his internet's a
little spotty so he's gonna sit this one
out um but he wishes he was here but
inshallah man go in
so um
which i carry on yeah go for it
so
where was that
so i was um i went home for christmas
and then
my sister so basically a week before i
go home for christmas my sister's
calling me saying yo mom's cleaned your
like deep cleaned your whole room and
obviously i'm hiding islamic books in
the corners of my room you know i'm
talking about at the back of shelves
like
under my desk and i'm thinking
she's definitely he's definitely seen
all of me
so i'm panicking i'm like cool
like literally me and my friend we write
a whole script of what i'm gonna say
i'm gonna be a nah nah i was my friend i
had to look after that wasn't gonna work
by the way so i called my mama like yo
mom you're good
she's just normal she's like yeah yeah
i'm come on come on how was how was uni
and stuff how's your new stuff
so i feel like they're loki loki opening
up to it i'm not sure about my dad
because my dad you know
i love my dad of all my heart but he's a
bit you know i don't blame him for it
but he's a bit islamophobic like
extremely islamophobic but i don't blame
you for it
but um yeah i feel like they're opening
up to it man
man
so you never formally had like that sit
down you're like pops
listen listen this is what it is this is
this is how it's got to be done you can
love me
but it's not going to change you didn't
have that yet
no the thing is
i can't lie to you it's been quite bad
because i've been pushing it off i keep
saying i'm like i'm going to do it cool
i'm going to do it next week and next
week and when the time comes my booze
are busted i can't do it i just get too
nervous
bro i'm not gonna lie like most people
have this like this fantasy that it's
gonna be a perfect sit down conversation
but it rarely ever is it's bits and
pieces of revealing that you're muslim
it could be intentional
or it could be unintentional like her
cleaning your room and eventually most
people i know it just gets to a point
where when you do tell them it's kind of
like they already knew you know
it's the type of thing as well i'm also
i'm not gonna expose his name but masha
allah
[Music]
about two weeks ago
he comes up to me the saddest i've ever
seen and he's like yo salaam bro i'm in
this exact same situation you of my
parents my parents aren't accepting it
and i've got another friend as well a
girl
she reverted as well my parents the
exact same reaction they don't accept it
they don't want her to be muslim and
stuff but to be fair i don't blame the
parents to think like that just because
of you know how the western
media portrays yeah yeah
it's almost like bro you could say
anything yo i started the keto diet yo
i'm going to uni yo i want to start a
business as soon as it's like hey mom a
muslim what you could do anything else
with your life but you want to be muslim
so it's apparently the craziest thing is
is the craziest thing is it's like
obviously i don't blame my parents for
this but
like
my parents i remember my parents are
asking me
yo yo are you going clubbing are you
going clubbing
so they'd rather i feel like they'd
rather me being a club than being a
mosque yeah
yeah man it's crazy but alhamdulillah
make it easy for you and mela get it
quick that they understand and they're
on board with the struggle bro because
you know once you it's almost like
you know i don't want to you know claim
i know your life better than you do but
for more rivers than
i've been told they stuck between living
this double life bro where it's like
one way but then they gotta act another
way you know and i feel like telling
them and being congruent with them is
the perfect thing that you all could do
to just kind of be congruent and
transparent and authentic it's no longer
gonna have to be this journey but until
you get there inshallah may allah give
you you know patience and ease
i mean
yeah i think you might be a little a
little laggy you think so okay noise
all right
and by the way did you call my name
because if you did you might have been
lagging when you said that so i didn't
get it
all right anyways i'm going to take over
allah allah bless you man it's honestly
an honor and a blessing being here with
you brother
you know the first thing that came to my
mind when telling your story is
he says if only the people like the
nations that he sent messengers to if
only they had accepted islam allah would
have opened up the heavens and the earth
with blessings for them but they
rejected it
yeah they rejected and then basically
were punished for that uh and that was
my first thoughts about allah and my
second one
was where allah says in the quran do you
think you're going to be left alone
saying that you know we believe
it won't be tested um and you know the
most amazing part of it
is both parts are tests the blessing is
the test
and the lack thereof is a test allah he
says in surah al-fajr he says when he
tests his servant
and gives them risk they say allah has
honored me but when he tests his servant
and restricts it they say allah has
humiliated me
and it's beautiful
yeah what do you mean by like the
restricts no it's kind of what you mean
by like the restricting thing yeah so
when allah gives you risk he's giving
you right when he reflects your risk
he's taking it away oh okay
so
honestly bro subhanallah a lot of the
time when you hear reverse and you know
even muslims who live in more
traditional cultural homes than islamic
homes even if they are muslim by name
you find a lot of the same stuff and
what you said about your parents would
rather see you in a club than see you in
a masjid
honestly bro
there's a lot of like boring muslims in
the muslim families where they'd rather
see them with a girlfriend than have
them try and get married
literally and it's like
it is tough out here in general but i do
agree that the sooner you kind of rip
that band-aid off and you have that
discussion with them
uh the sooner they will be open to
accepting and the reason i say that is
because let's say you wait five years to
tell them
they're gonna go through a process of
understanding learning and that stuff
either you start it now and they
are cool in three months from now or you
tell them five five years from now and
then in five years and three months
they're cool with it you know what i
mean yeah yeah yeah i get that yeah yeah
but i think the most impactful thing
my friend is gonna be your character and
how they see your character has changed
if they see you're more upbeat yeah 100
percent
you're taking care of them you're making
your mom tea you're clean cleaning up
for her and you know uh doing errands
and tasks for your dad and stuff and
then ask you why you're doing this you
sit them down you have that talk and be
like listen i'm a muslim we're supposed
to honor our parents and how's your dad
gonna be like no you're a terrorist fan
no loki loki i've been doing that
because you know my me my parents i love
my parents today i love them today we
haven't had the best relationship of
recent years
but it's the type of thing where as soon
as that's muslim right bro
i remember my friend told me like
janna is under your mother's feet
like that's how important your mom is in
islam and i was like
from then i just panned up like my mom
like i love my mom so much
and i started treating her way but i
started you know doing chores around the
house started you know doing things that
will make her smile
so hopefully when i actually tell her
properly i'm going to be like yeah the
reason i've been doing this is because
allah told me to do this
you can always reach out to me
insha'allah if you need any advice
of course my brother of course all right
so
now we talked a lot about family and
kind of the the dynamics around that
perhaps the struggle around that
but i want to maybe flick the switch a
little bit you talked about some of the
hardships i do want to hear more about
the hardships of being a reaver you
sound like uk is that right you're from
the uk did i get sir are you from the uk
yeah yeah yeah okay
i know that it could be rough out there
that's why the the brotherhood down
there is so strong because
the kind of the fire against islam burns
a lot more there unfortunately so
yeah go on
again but you know the brotherhood
or the brotherhood in islam i was not
expecting that atu like i'm talking
about
when
you know when i meet someone and then
we're talking for 30 minutes the
conversations is cool and then somehow
islam gets brought up i'm like oh yeah
i'm a muslim
the way their face glows oh my it's like
i'm looking at the sun it's crazy they
give me a hug it's everything man it's
the best thing
may allah elevate you immensely bro
uh that's a beautiful thing
like it makes me very very happy to hear
that and i i
see myself in those brother's shoes any
day of the week that when a brother
especially when you don't expect a
brother to be muslim when they say they
are it's like it does kind of make your
day
so
that's you know something that's very
beautiful about reverting and kind of
getting that brotherhood but
i want to hear more about some of the
hardships and some of the blessings that
you've had as a muslim
there's you know there's been way more
blessings and hardships 100
way way way more blessing some of their
blessings are just
every like
like going back to the brotherhood thing
the brotherhood thing is such a good
thing like
uh because i come from croydon and
that's like a very densely muslim
populated area that's hella like
bengalis
somalians there's there's like you know
all these like there's so many muslims
and
i was kind of entered into this
brotherhood
when i was
obviously i reverted obviously a lot of
people had imagined and i started
turning to jummah so much love
so much love like
the love i've turned from being since
i've avoided the love i've felt i've
like i've never felt this in my entire
life
like
it's actually crazy
as in
people calling me your rakeem let's
leave the house you know what i mean
it's like okay well that was a rubbish
example but
people will be calling me saying yo yo
yo how are you people always checking up
on me
you know what i mean and like and before
i never ever had that before i never had
people die doing stuff like that
the hardships are you know obviously the
parent thing
and
that's it really just a parent thing but
the blessings are like the tick tock
even the tick tock i consider that a
blessing because you know i like
grinding me with this massive platform
that i can you know speak to when i can
educate and i can help and they can also
help me
you know i mean
but yeah man it's been a blessing but
it's been way more of a blessing than
you know a curse why don't i be a
cosplayer
alhamdulillah
when all devices are connected to the
internet bro it just just gets crappy
bro but regardless man you dm'd us that
you wanted to talk about some real stuff
you know some stuff that
you know you don't hear every now and
then bro it's not stuff necessarily just
about you know reverting and all this
it's like some deeper stuff bro so do
you have any questions for us before we
you know go on to that
how is it yeah how is it being you know
masha'allah you have a
like a massive following
how has it been having that like as
muslims
like that live in new york as well
i bro so you are right
time zone but me and rami are based in
toronto right which is in canada
and but it's all good bro it's all good
and angel is from
right now he used to be in florida too
which is along the new york time zone
um
but now he's in thailand but anyway are
you asking like how our experience has
been
with
our our influence and and all of this in
youtube
yeah and i also ask you about like hey
did you get any hate by the way
oh bro listen so rami please
remind me if i forget to bring you know
answer the second question right about
the haters the unmuted mind
is mad but to answer your first question
bro when it comes to how we've handled
it
i was literally talking to rami about
this two days ago
the way we handle stuff the way we
navigate the way we course correct the
way we do anything alhamdulillah is like
a million times better now since we
started because when we started we
didn't know what we were doing right now
it's almost like we have to like
proactively avoid issues that come up
before they even come up and when they
do we have to handle it the way we do
but in in terms of the baraka bro it's
kind of like what you said bro we did
our best to put our right foot forward
and do everything for the sake of allah
and not have any ulterior dunya
gains and motives right and because of
that allah has been over delivering
subhanallah we've been doing this on
youtube for just a year
right if you see some of our older
videos all three of us are using our
iphones literally no mic
literally like normal you know no intro
no animation no nothing and
alhamdulillah in a year bro 40k subs
this is unheard of this is literally
just because we're doing everything you
know for the sake of allah one thing
that angel mentioned in a stream or two
ago that i really agree with it's valid
it's
we were working on you know how do we
you know bless up the algorithm how do
we make insane thumbnails how do we do
this and it was kind of helping bro but
the second that me and angel really took
seriously uh the islamic education in
terms of like learning the team because
rami's been on the alhamdulillah for a
long time compared to us as soon as you
know we all three of us basically got on
that times ten
everything just took off with youtube
a lot of people can attribute it to you
know thumbnails or tags or optimization
or click whatever but it's like nothing
clicked until that clicked for us
that's the first thing so my advice to
anyone is if you take a step in the you
know path of allah just watch allah over
delivers and allah doesn't even have to
over deliver allah doesn't always
anything but the fact that allah does
and gives us that kind of feedback that
you know reinforcement that we're on the
right path it is good to have that you
know so that's one and number two in
terms of the hate rami bro just just
tell them about the trolls
a lot of people whether it comes from
people who claim to be muslim people who
claim to be muslim but clearly or not
people who are you know part of certain
communities um i've been called
everything i've been called homophobic
i've been called homosexual i've been
called all these different things just
for you know my beliefs and i know faith
has gotten his you know
sheriff buddy i get the homo homophobic
how how were you called homosexual bro i
don't know
yeah
that the people that like like dislike i
don't dislike them but the people that
dislike them the most are like low-key
closeted
so many times everyone tells me that
yeah yeah yeah
we don't we bro we don't hate them but
it's just like because our ideology
doesn't align with their ideology they
feel it's kind of like feminists bro
feminists think we hate them bro we
don't hate feminists we like i don't
wake up every day and i'm just like how
do i just make their lives miserable bro
i don't i pity them honestly but it's
like if only they knew that what they're
on is not the straight path you know
what i mean it's more like just
yeah yeah yeah 100 we get a lot of those
comments from from people whether
they're straight up hateful like i bro i
had um
people someone literally commenting on
my recent post i was just a thumbnail
literally shouting out on one live
stream we're doing and someone commented
saying i'm uh
um how do i say it a b u a b u s e
apologist and like r a p e apologist
okay yeah i've never been bro like in my
life i've never like
saved lives
there's a rakeem bro i'm gonna tell you
one thing and uh rami bro you lagged out
so i hope you were done because i want
to cut you off
but we have a brother right he has a
youtube channel too his name is gabriel
romani if you've been watching this long
enough you know brother gabriel
mashallah is doing his wonderful thing
with the thousand
the best advice that he's ever given us
right i tell everyone this this is
literally the best advice
if you are on the huck and you are doing
everything you can to like speak truth
in a world full of falsehood and
obviously you know i'm not saying just
be narcissistic and post whatever you
want if you need this go to scholars you
know go to should i pose it should i not
obviously that's you know
but once you do that literally stop
obsessing or caring about dms and
requests and all these comments because
people will always have something to say
about everything he told me that the day
he stopped giving a down about that is
the day that he his mental peace of mind
and his his stability just just went
tenfold
so thank you
yeah we would literally like try to like
post like proper stuff and then someone
would have a problem with that we would
fix that and then someone would have a
problem with that so we got to a point
where we're like no matter what we do we
could literally be perfect bro the
prophet saw was literally flipping
madinah upside down when he got
revelation everyone was going against
him at the time so
and that's not going to change bro what
do you think is going to happen today
and what's weird is it's the muslims
that are giving us fitnah bro it's not
really the non-muslims per se because
the non-muslims we don't care bro
when you're showing up in a hijab you're
showing up in a though you're showing up
as a brother or sister and you're coming
out sideways bro you know for no reason
you know and people really lost that
touch bro yeah 100 they they will
literally pull up like what's your akida
what's your math hub what do you follow
uh and they're literally comfy like
you're not scholars like you shouldn't
be on this yeah
yeah and it's like
you saying that shows you clearly you
don't even know the basics of that
if you teach for me even if it's just
one ayah so if all i knew was one ayah
that's enough for me to be online
preaching that one ayah every single day
of my life subhanallah so honestly bro
you're you're gonna get hate comments
you're you're gonna get the people that
are like bro look at this you know asian
guy yeah yeah yeah
you know who are you you're fake you're
doing it for clout all this stuff bro
they don't know a lot of people have
said that
yeah
it always goes back to bigotry to racism
to idiocy to their honesty bro they're
just morons and once you start seeing
them in that life like
they don't know you right they don't
know you they can't possibly know you
and they're claiming these things about
you there's nothing backing that except
of some kind of arrogance or ignorance
or intolerance and all those things can
bro they can go to the hellfire we don't
care for them as soon as you you'll know
when a brother sincere when they're
giving you advice you're trying to be
nice and that's when you can
differentiate go be as
possible as a brother and and you'll you
will see who's who's this here and who's
insincere bro just just take taken
you're going to go on this april team
called tick tock right it's a flipping
vertical app it's not even like proper
like you know hd rubs or anything just a
little vertical thing you know just
selfie mode you're just saying whatever
you want to say and someone halfway
across the world is going to be so
triggered by what you're saying that
they're literally going to make fake
accounts they're literally going to like
make fake accounts and and and write you
know rakim whatever trying to you know
act like you posting dumb stuff viruses
like bro people need to get a life man
honestly you know who would have hate
comments all the all the accounts have
about five followers and they're just
following that 400 people these are
bored they're just making fake accounts
people have a lot of audacity when you
can't see their face when you don't know
their name well they have so much on
that it's like the call of duty lobbies
bro they have so much ideas
i'm just about to say that yeah
i'm not gonna lie to you um yeah i know
going back to what you said a lot of the
hate
is from other muslims a lot of the hate
i get is from other muslims like
when i tell when i tell you know when i
tell um
a non-muslim i'm muslim or like i'm
doing something
they're like
but to be fair i don't blame them
because as muslims we should be helping
each other but there's a certain way to
do it there's a way that it's not like
attacking because most of the time
they're just attacking the most of time
they're attacking me yeah i mean
100
and uh it is bro honestly
you know if honestly i would take every
situation where you feel hurt by what
someone says as a learning opportunity
because bro there was one time i was
getting dragged through the damn ringer
on tick tock like
i don't know if you saw it if you didn't
alhamdulillah if you did it is what it
is people were dragging me through the
ringer that stuff i mentioned before
about the apologist thing people were
dragging my name my face everything and
like ripping me bro i had i had
literally sisters who wanted at one
point they like literally said they want
to marry me
uh they these same sisters making doubt
that i never get married and never have
a daughter and all these different
things were hating me wow
for the worst part when it passed by
they came back they came back i think
nothing enough
like nothing
the one sister's like oh i'm always here
i'm always first i'm like you were
literally just in my comments making god
against me get out of my life get out of
here but that's how i
love you you're gonna
you can hear it all bro i literally
heard like i curse your future kids your
wives i hope you never have kids i hope
if you have kids they turn against you i
heard you know what you say on youtube
makes me want to take my own life and
i'm just like bro what yeah is it hard
is that haram to say that like if you
curse someone like oh i will insha allah
something bad happens
i i don't know about that because
answer that but what i do know islamic
etiquette is to always assume good of
your muslim brother and sister to never
come sideways backbiting is one thing
right backbiting is basically talking
about someone else behind their back
even if it's true
you know
slandering which is which is falsehood
you know assuming things wrongly and
just you know misrepresenting them
that's even worse than backbiting in
islam and that's what people are doing
literally yeah 100 so i asked my sheikh
about this because you know when i have
people making their against me in my
comments i have to ask like so you know
it's a logan except this dude like
what's going on
well it's a worrisome thing bro
he said
as far as i know the only time allah
will accept the dua like that is if one
is already predestined it's gonna happen
to you anyways or two uh you are
oppressing the person because allah will
accept against an oppressor against
someone who's you know causing
corruption but if you're a good servant
and like let's say because either you're
wrong in what you did to them or they're
wrong in making the dua against you
right if you're if you're chill and they
did the wrong then allah would not
accept that they are against you so i
think i think you don't have to worry
about that kind of stuff bro should we
just like um against that don't know
what trump or something
if it's like it comes through should we
just make dua against that donald trump
or something
yeah you know what bro it's not they're
oppressors these leaders they know what
they're doing um
you can make dog dance i would advise
you know as the prophet said um
you heard the story when he was like
and the people were throwing stones and
like oh yeah yeah
he sat i think by a tree or something
and the angel jibreel that is he said i
can take this mountain i could take this
mountain and i can smash the people in
between them
the facade of me said
i'm paraphrasing but he said i have high
hopes that their children will accept
islam so like leave them
he just got stoned like like had stuff
thrown at him spit he was bleeding he
was attacked
by like like
all these people men women children
slaves like all these people and he was
still being merciful saying i have hopes
that their children will accept islam in
sha allah and then their children did
afterwards
so we should make that first but yeah
can i ask you a question
what's your biggest dream as a muslim
biggest dream
what do you even have one
like
like my biggest dream is to become a
herpes just because i heard that you
know if you become at her feast you
could bring 10 people into jannah and i
start from allah my parents they don't
accept islam i could bring them into
jannah
you know what i mean
that is such a good answer and such good
intention
and may allah you know allow you to
fulfill that
times a million bro but that kind of you
know reminded me of my answer initially
i thought i got no answer but now i know
what you mean by that question
my muslim dream has as corny as it
sounds bro my muslim dream is one day i
want to get to a point where
money doesn't matter right so in terms
of passive income and just you know you
don't have to actively trade time for
money and what i could do with my time
is literally just travel the world
give back pay it forward build you know
masjids build wealth generating these
build schools give people what they
don't have and that's all i do with my
free time literally just have the
passive income that i'm coming in which
enables the time and the baraka and the
resources to just pay it forward and
that's that's really the perfect life
that i want to leave bro
that's beautiful
man honestly i just want to get to
jannah
i just want to get to january i want to
bring as many people to the path as
possible i want to help as many people
as possible at the end of the day man i
want to get general child that's my goal
looking at me you know bro bro that
could be that's probably every muscle
goal man do you have anything a little
more dunya oriented at least something a
little more measurable
honestly man i don't want to put a
number on it because
there's not there's never going to be a
point where i have done enough you know
what i mean so i just every opportunity
i have i want to help insha allah and do
my best until i die
and have allah for me
okay that's that's good that's a great
answer bro
talking about jannah bro
udi sans man is scaring me man
um
some guy told me it's really bad talk
about the judgment
what
no bro listen
but there's so much
or innovation that people literally just
make up rules left and right
the the point of the prophet's coming
was to remind people to worship allah
and warn them about the day of judgment
that's literally every single prophet
that came they warned people about the
day of judgment and tell them to prepare
for it so why are we going to sit here
and pretend hell doesn't exist and you
know there's no afterlife and stuff
that's the most i want to i want to
quickly say before rami goes on that we
don't have any malice towards the
brother that told you that may love
bless him bro we i'm still going to come
at it assuming that he meant the best
intention forward but there's a lot of
culture associated like subhanallah the
prophet saws never had any type of
skirmish behavior talking about intimacy
he would talk to the youth talk to the
teens you know be very open about that
but in today's asian or arab or desi
culture parents are extremely shy about
that type of stuff until the kid's 25
and they're like why don't you have a
kid already and the kids like i don't
even know how damn i don't even know how
to talk to a woman bro
that's that's like one example right so
the brother might just have heard it
somewhere but anyway bro
yeah that's uh
i think that that basically summarizes
it that there's a lot of people that you
know kind of they talk from a secular
western perspective so every time you
hear something like that like don't talk
about this don't talk about that a lot
of the time if it's a part of the dean
that's literally the the point of the
dean that we talk about it that we
spread it out
we learn it so
um yeah i'm glad that [ __ ] he
said what he said was a lot because you
know we should assume the best maybe my
my response was a little too bitter but
not like i i know you responded like
that though sometimes i respond like
that as well
yo rami could you paraphrase this for
brother kimbro i don't exactly remember
what sheikh with one said but it was so
yeah
bro keep this yeah i like gasps bro when
he said this so there's the verse in the
quran
i mean honestly bro it's a beautiful
thing and if it scares us it's in a good
way right
so there's a verse in the quran i think
in surah i think it's either
but allah says he he created death
and life
to see which of us is best in deeds
right and he said that the scholars
they say that verse where allah says he
created death and he created life
um to see which is best whose best in
deeds
this kind of like why does allah say
death first when first we live and then
we die
so we thought about it for a bit and he
said the scholars say that when allah
says he created death he's actually
talking about this life
when allah said he created death peace
he's referring to this life and when he
says life he's referring to the next
life
because if you think our life hasn't
even started yet our life if you really
think about this dunya the only thing
that happens in the grand scheme is we
die
like that's it bro nobody makes our life
you know and and that's really it and
the second thing is we're born we really
start the eternal life
so i don't know
yeah because when you think about it
life is so
you're not even gonna i'm we're not even
gonna remember this like
i'm like we're in january we're not even
gonna remember this life
yeah we're not gonna remember like if
we're you know what there's actually a
hadith around that
and as far as i know it mentions that a
person will live the best of life and
i'm paraphrasing but a person will live
an amazing life in this world and
they'll be dipped into hellfire for like
a second and they'll come out saying
i've never seen anything good in my life
and the person that has had the worst
life in this earth they'll be dipped
into jannah for a second and they'll
come out saying i've never seen anything
bad in my life just from a second agenda
so the ill the bad all that stuff we
won't remember that pain but we'll be
able to remember like oh rakeem remember
that time we did that live stream and it
reminded people of allah no yeah yeah
yeah that brought us here
allah we can say that inshallah
i mean
bro but speaking of the signs at the end
of times man before we go deeper into
that has there been anything that you
particularly noticed about just living
life
you know day by day anything that
reminds you that bro the end is really
near
no
i think about it a lot i can't like i
think about it like a lot like in my
head i'm like when i'm about to do
something i shouldn't
like i'm in my head i'm like nah i'm not
trying to lie
i'm not obviously like if i'm doing it
while we know like when the trumpet
blows i'm not trying to you know
i just get hella scared
and it's the type of thing where i'm
like
it kind of keeps me on track you know i
mean it keeps me and keeps me grounded
it's kind of a good thing actually it is
bro just that's the thing like a lot of
people don't know this but you can
google obviously assuming you know you
look at authentic sources of like signs
of the end of times hadith you know or
things that are going to happen events
before young okiyama and bro just
looking at the things that are going to
happen
like subhanallah you look at society you
look at how men and women are today you
look how systems are you look at the
people that are power
you look at the buildings around you bro
every hadith that was narrating what's
going to happen before the time is near
it's literally around us and and nobody
bro forget 1400 years ago an illiterate
man that couldn't read it right
prophesizing this forget that no one
even 500 years ago could have made these
claims
even when he was like there's going to
be a voice talking in your pocket and
he's talking about phones he said he's
going to listen to the music playing
inside of your ears
subhanallah like
to be fair i feel like
if i was to you know give dawah to
anyone in like in hopes of them
reverting i would just tell them this
because there's no there's no way this
is false that's the thing like i feel
like if people were taught this in
schools
everyone would be muslim
everyone would be muslim because there's
no way this is false
there's no way this is fake
and talking about the two buildings
people compete to vote for buildings
there's literally
architecture like people
like there's actually architecture for
people building bigger buildings
in 2040 and there's
there's blueprint there's blueprints for
a bigger building than baj khalifa and
people in china made
blueprints to out build make a bigger
toilet than those blueprints like that's
here's the thing that's that's the thing
the prophet saws didn't say one day
people are going to build tall buildings
the prophet saws literally narrated that
arabs are going to compete
in building all buildings which subhan
there's no way around it bro i don't
know how anyone can deny the evidence
just looking at it bro yeah
i just want to address this sister salah
talked about dajjal and i know you
wanted to talk about the gel too so
inshallah stay tuned we're going to go
into that but rami what's up i just
wanted to say just to add to the hadith
in terms of context the process said
this in a desert imagine all of us were
standing like a wasteland or like a
desert and i'm like you know what rakim
there's going to come a time where
people
these naked you know sheep hurting
people that we see
uh some of them barely have enough to
get by and these people are gonna
compete with other nations and building
tall buildings bro we are like in a
desert and i'm telling you that like
yeah that's the thing the the society
the environment is going to be perfectly
cultivated to just welcome the coming of
the job
and that's the thing when i was new into
islam right i really didn't understand
balancing you know reason with logic
when you're coming from you know being a
non-muslim or even if you're born muslim
but you're coming from a jahilia right
we're used to using logic bro logic is a
man-made construct that we use to solve
problems that we created ourselves in
the dunya we can't limit allah to logic
so it's like when you learn about the
jal or ajujin
how does it logically make sense it
doesn't know allah living hundreds of
years you know muslims splitting the sea
bro how does it make logical sense it
doesn't right and and non-muslims will
use this against us bro subhanallah but
this is the exact case that i'm going to
bring forward that why are we using
logic to describe things about allah and
things that shouldn't even make sense
with logic
yeah
i've looked he got a theory about this
go for it bro
you see with like all this development
in technology
i feel like
the gel is gonna use all of these things
to like guide people away from the dean
do you know what i'm talking about
because there's obviously preparations
for the digella to come right yeah
like one of the things is that he's
going to be able to speak every language
in japan they've developed an earpiece
that you put in your ear you will talk
and it will translate it in your ear
yeah and i feel like you know like have
you look this is going to be weird have
you not seen spiderman
but like the one with jake gallon
well he has like some some metaverse yes
he has this thing where it's like you're
literally immersed in vr like say if
like there's a there's like a
holographic cake in front of you you're
seeing it in real time like it's real
and with the new emergence of when i
first heard about the metaverse i was
like bro
the gianlis gonna use this metaphor
because you're literally in a vr set
moving around
i feel like they're gonna develop to a
point where your consciousness is inside
of this metaverse
100 percent like not you're not far off
without theory listen
literally and it's like it's like
the baby of like you're like the baby
stages of a phone was like a brick phone
you couldn't even
you couldn't even like you couldn't do
anything on it now on our phones we can
write the entire quran and it won't
crash
that was the baby like the baby stage of
a phone was a brick phone
the baby stage of vr is the headset i
feel like as it develops it's going to
get immersive and the girl is going to
be in there you know split a person in
half bring them back together you know
what i mean yeah bro that makes does
that make sense that makes sense bro
there's listen elon musk is already
creating stuff like neurolink bro which
is they literally put electrodes in your
brain and it's like you're literally
fully immersed there's other vr's that
you literally feel pain when you feel
pain in the vr world and it's like
there's there's there's a dowel
organization i'm not gonna you know call
any names up but this dao organization
is huge they're on youtube they're
they're very you know you know famous
for bringing a lot of people on the
screen at once um i'll leave you guys
with that and alhamdulillah they're
doing great work and they're they're
having these vr events these vr dollar
boots and all that
i'm personally not giving a fatwa now
right because i'm not a scholar i'm
personally not saying anything bad about
them but a lot of people send us their
work and they're just like why don't you
guys come to their vr events why don't
you guys come to their vr dial events
you guys should be speakers here bro i
will never as long as i'm alive i see no
reason to get anywhere close to the vr
and immerse myself into the metaverse
bro there's far more danger that could
happen than good and we made an episode
bro shameless plug it's about 50 minutes
long you know type up the three muslims
metaverse
see what we talked about that in the in
that episode this is literally perfectly
for the end times to come bro just like
you're saying being in the universe it's
like you're literally not even going to
realize what's happening in front of you
bro
can i you don't know about jack parsons
as well with their technology yeah are
you talking about the man that uh he
created the space field to go into yeah
right yeah he literally met he mentioned
the jail by name bro
did he wrote this in his
endeavor
that is insane to me
and people still don't people still
don't believe
it's insane to me
that's the thing why why would this why
would this man i believe he's from
pasadena california why would a man from
from the states randomly like long ago
decades ago he was not muslim by the way
but he was doing a lot of dmt he was
doing a lot of drugs that open up your
consciousness to next levels you know
haram by the way you know i don't advise
anyone to do it stay away from that um
alhamdulillah for islam but
that's what he was doing he's a
non-muslim guy and he came into
existence he came into contact with
these gin and these you know they call
it dmt entities we we have this series
that we did with mr middlepath it's like
the jin series and we talk about how a
lot of people they they have dmt
entities like when they do dmt they come
into they come into contact with these
you know entities right they're just gin
bro and they're the same things that
people when they say i've been abducted
by aliens right all of these reports are
aligned the way they describe it it's
all general but anyway my point is when
when jack parsons did these things he
was a space engineer right
the man that made space travel possible
for for rockets to just propel and and
break out of the stratosphere right the
man that made this possible when he did
dmt
he literally came across this this one
being that gave him the formula to make
that possible and when he asked that
that being who are you
he said i'm the job and he wrote this
and
after he he came out with this and the
rocket fuel was successful and
everything his whole house blew on fire
and he passed away
i don't think that's a coincidence bro
well it's mid it's like oh but i'm hella
scared it's not 1am
that's crazy
yeah
that's insane a lot um and the the
theory i've heard it before about like
the you know the child would use uh
what's it called like technology and
that stuff i personally don't think it's
that far off i don't think it's that
like crazy to believe that especially in
the age that we're living in now uh in
the prophet salam when he would describe
things he was describing it to his
people so he had to say in a way that
would make sense enough so he couldn't
say cell phone satellite vr
metaverse
you know like things like that
uh
the only thing that kind of comes to my
mind is the the story of the island of
the job do you guys know about that
yeah i heard about that bro
yeah there's a hadith basically
describing that some men who were
sailing in the ocean their ship kind of
they lost course and they ended up on
this island and they saw this beast
where it was it was big it was hairy and
they couldn't tell it's front from its
back and it spoke
and then it brought them to this place
where there was a man locked up like
physically there locked up and these are
multiple men who were sailing that found
this in real life um and he was don't
worry about nothing
don't worry he's he's locked on an
island insha'allah but
basically
uh he he basically said
and he gave some prophecies as well i
think he said that i won't come out
until this happens and that happens and
there's a video on it if you guys want
to go watch it called the island of the
jab uh and then these men they went to
the russell afterwards they told him
about it and he basically informed me
that was the jal and all of that stuff
so the only problem i see with the
technology stuff and him not actually
having powers is how would a story like
that be true if it didn't happen in real
life and that this is the thing at the
end of the day the process he gave us
enough to recognize it not enough to
decipher exactly how it's going to be
and exactly how it's going to happen
all we need to know in a day is when we
see him we'll know what's him it'll be
clear he'll have cather he'll be hunched
over he'll have one eye that's like a
floating grape and it'll be so clear
we're going to be he's probably standing
there in shock like all the hadith
running through our head like you know
our forehead rape eye hunched over and
uh
we're probably gonna be shocked
by the end of the day we'll know it's
him have you not seen that
yeah you're not going bro
have you not seen that there was this
guy
in spain i think i don't know if it was
photoshopped or not but a stuff for a
lot you know he got carefully attacked
on his forehead
can you say that one more time
so there was this guy in spain i don't
know if it was a fraud or hoax but he
got carefully tattooed on his forehead
because i don't i think that's a fraud
or hoax bro because there's there's no
way like you know that's that's the
thing bro like the gel
from what we know is you know a lot of
hadith i don't know how it's ending
there but he's already here it's not
like the gel is going to come into
existence he's already here other ones
you know i've heard that he's going to
come so i don't know but if a man is
doing that bro it's kind of like a lot
of people have come claiming they're the
false messiah like
mahdi a lot of people have claimed to be
you know the second coming and all this
nonsense bro people are going to try to
claim these things anyway
isn't that like hello
oh yeah very uh 100 and you know what
subhan allah
praying that brother our king can sleep
tonight allah
uh the thing about the thing about the
jad is if you think about it
there's and everything i'm about to say
is a bit skeptical so no one take it as
fact
the only thing that is certain is that i
know of is the process he said that most
of the followers of the jal
will be women that's that's all i can
say like somewhat firmly everything else
is a bit speculative so
i think there is narration talking about
he's going to come from the east and
some scholars say this means palestine
right
so
and if you think about palestine what is
it now there's you know israel
and you know the craziest part is they
don't believe in an antichrist they
think that messiah is coming for them to
save them so when a man comes claiming
to be messiah doing these miracles and
all this stuff they're going to believe
him bro and that's going to be his main
following
and that's the thing bro it's like
the there's a hadith i believe it's
authentic too but it says most of the
followers of the jail are going to be
women and jews right
i know a lot of women are going to come
up sideways and oh t3m is you know
sexist t3m doesn't like women listen
it's not the fact that women are
inferior or anything like that but it's
the fact that women like provisioning
and security more than us they need that
bro biologically speaking they need that
so when the gel comes and the child
promises all these securities in a world
and in chaos brought the time in
destruction and makes all these miracles
happen makes all these fake things come
into existence fulfills all these
fantasies for you women are gonna you
know fall victim to that bro that's why
the prophet saws said when the job comes
to the men literally chain down your
women at home it doesn't mean any any
type of you know anything like that but
it just means you'll protect them bro
because they're gonna fall for that
and the jews just like rami saying the
jews are gonna take that as the messiah
right because they don't know about
antichrist like christians and muslims
they just think you know we're going to
have a messiah that comes and we're
going to follow him bro
yeah 100 and you know what bro at the
end of the day that that thing about the
women and the jews is just a statistic
like if i say most people in prison
right now are men you're going to call
me sexist i'm just reporting the fact
it's not my fault no i didn't make it
that way um actually the people who
perhaps people who made society made it
in a way where men are more likely to go
to prison than women
not on account of men being different
but maybe on the count of three system
just being wrong that's not my fault you
know it's reporting a statistic uh so no
i'm gonna say
yeah it also could be like because you
know like a sign of their judgment
there's gonna be like what
two times as much woman as men am i
wrong in that thing
i believe it'll get to a point where
there's gonna be 50 times as much women
as men
yeah yes so that could be why you know
most of the jazz followers are mostly
women
and and there's also another hadith
saying that one day the sun is going to
rise from the west but we can talk about
this all day and night subhanallah but
that's the thing
it's going to come a point where the sun
is literally going to rise from the west
and then people are going to be like all
right i'll submit now but it's like bro
it might be too late at that time
you know in china
you know in china
don't don't even say i know where you're
going yeah yeah yeah
it was pitch black midnight they made
the sun they made
there was something some scientific
study that was done they said that the
china's second sun it was 9 000 times
hotter than the real sun
that's crazy
the only thing isn't china like far to
the east especially compared to like
saudi arabia
they made the sun bro it's almost like
people are looking at like all right
let's google the prophet saws prophecies
of the end of times and let's just like
make them into existence one on one bro
what is this yeah that's crazy i also
heard like a more uh
theoretical thing where they were saying
that at the the way the earth is turning
now eventually it's going to slow down
to the point where it stops and then
it's going to start going the other way
so now
yeah think about it like this
yeah i mean that's theoretical you can't
say for sure but that's what some people
are saying so imagine like this this is
the sun right here right if i turn this
way it rises from the right side right
yeah turn around it's going to rise from
the left side so it's kind of like that
once the earth spins the other way it
starts rising from the west instead
that's another thing uh but bro all we
know is that when it
comes it's gonna the doors of taobao are
like they're closed it's too late once
you see that sign it's like
bro
turn everything around at that point
yeah it's harmful enough it is landline
mm-hmm
so many christian believe something
stuff it was hard for me to change my
views on on it but i have
uh khadija
do you mind elaborating on that so we
know what you mean and west right
there's already been a study that there
are more women being born than men
nowadays subhanallah bro
omar writes the jaws locked up on an
island in earth mentioned in hadith what
about gagan magog yeah bro
do you know about that or not
yeah yeah i know i can't lie
this might be bad to say but i hope i'm
dead because that is so scary yeah
they're coming they they they're
chipping away at the wall
and then
yeah that's the thing it's like it's
like every single day they try to like
break free
from from the place that dulcane locked
them in and every time they just get
close
it's just not today it's going to be
another day but one day i forget what it
is i think there's an angel keeping an
eye on them but i feel like one day the
angel is going to say you know it's not
the angels i'm going to stop them and
they're just going to keep going
and it's literally narrated specifically
what's going to happen how much crops
they're going to eat how much people
they're going to you know hunt down and
it says everything clearly and and
subhanallah you'll have people say yo
gogan magog or metaphor
what do you mean metaphor bro you really
think it's like you know so i don't know
someone said that jiao is a metaphor for
like the trials and tribulations that
we're going to go through no bro the gel
is specific
it's literal there's no metaphor for
this gog and magog on capitalism and
communism bro like people think it's not
these things are literal they're not
figurative whatsoever bro
i think a lot of the ahmadis they
project a view like that because they
believe that that mirza glam guy they
claim he was the messiah
but we know the messiah is going to kill
the antichrist so they try and claim
that well he has to be the messiah
therefore antichrist is metaphorical and
he ruined it with his preaching and
stuff but it is very very clear
literally
no but you know you know about like
what's the angel israel feel is it has
had his lips on the horn
yeah
he's your feel but think about what
israel sounds like sounds like israel
but anyway
angel so i remember when my friend taz
told me about that to see that he's
helped me a lot throughout my whole
reversion process but um
i remember the day i found out about
that
it was jummah i was on the bus back
and i heard this truck it was like
i thought it was the horn supernala bro
i thought this was it man it was so
scary i've never felt that fear in my
life
it's a good thing though
good thing for
sure you're not talking about the
prosthetic sun you know how it's gonna
be hella hella hella hot
you know how it's like
on the day of judgment the sun's gonna
be
burning up and you're gonna be covered
by the shade of allah
and i think only some believers as well
not not every believer
i i think may allah grant us that
i mean
bro do you got any other questions on
your mind what's up
i just want to learn more about islam
like anything like that
we we do this thing and i know we're
officially we're you know you're you're
open you're invited to come on the
podcast anytime bro
but you know usually at the end of the
stream what we do when we have you know
20 20 25 minutes you know at the end of
the stream left we like to open up the
stream to like anyone you know and they
can
ask questions and they will you know ask
you any questions because i'm sure
there's a lot of followers bro that you
have that are you know they're tuning in
right now it's hella late
asking questions bro why don't you take
over while i make it to uh anyone
without the chat
wait can i ask one just one question
quickly
but um
you see
you know like the dmt thing
is it true that in the quran it says
because because i feel like when you die
you experience like not a dmt trip thing
but it's something similar to like a dmt
trip
and i i remember reading on the reddit
so it's not very trusted
they said already like there's like a
thing in the quran that says you're not
allowed to experience these psychedelic
effects because when you die that's when
you're gonna experience them
because with the ego death and
everything
um that's my first time hearing it i
can't think of any verse on top of my
head that says something like that five
do you know about that what i'll say is
this bro
there's no doubt in my mind that these
drugs
dmt
shrooms lsd
they literally open you up
to another level that you're not
supposed to be in consciously 100
they open you up and they basically
allow you to to cross that bridge
there's things like astral projecting
bro where you can enter the the realm or
or dimension that jin are in you're not
supposed to do that normally allah has
put this hijab on us for a reason right
my point is these things you are able to
do it but it's clear in islam we have to
stay up from intoxicants and my mind
altering substances so there's no doubt
that these things are haram there's no
way that you know we're supposed to do
dmt or anything like that
that's crazy you say that because
i don't know if i'm allowed to talk
about this but obviously you know
can i talk about like my previous
careful life
i've done
some of this oh really
generally it's best to conceal your sins
yes
yeah yeah bro we'll send you we'll send
you a video um
that should make that answer clear bro
and then it speaks volumes way more into
that than we ever will
um but inshallah it'll make sense after
you see that video and it will really
keep a checkpoint what you saying don't
say because that video helped me
tremendously bro it was sent to me by
brother angel inshallah but we're just
going to quickly get through some of
these questions inshaallah and then we
can proceed
with allah the wallet right you
mentioned the john island it was
time of the prophet young jewish boy
whom the companions believed was the
jail but is understood to be a jinn yeah
i remember that bro that was crazy
um
all right
on scene is unseen for a reason facts
like
what do you say punch him yeah he said
punch him bro
i'm really i'm gonna read sort of the
calf bro
what happens when i revive yeah go for
it go for bro so talking about my friend
taz again obviously he's being like a
big helper
on the day of my reversion
he brought me to the mosque
i prayed before i even reverted in the
mosque because obviously we went for
with as a prayer was it yeah it was
and then obviously he spoke to your man
he was like yo my brother's trying like
my brother's trying to take he's
shahadah i took the shahadah i'm talking
about
ten brothers surrounding me
ten brothers surrounding me in a circle
i'm taking it and it just feels like
the maddest hug
like i'm
the feeling of me taking the shahada all
my days well if i could put it in a
bottle and drink it i'd live with it if
i could put that feeling in the bottle
and drink it i'd inject it in myself it
was like i should say that but it was
the craziest craziest feeling
and then me and taz
so i like i felt like lifted onto
another level
do you know what i mean
and then
me and times were like cool i took my
shahada we exchanged i exchanged my
number with all these brothers i'm out
of the mosque i'm talking about it was
like
it was winter
so like it's gloomy as hell
there's like the clouds here the cloud
is like a slip a slit of sunlight
beaming onto the masjid the whole world
is blue the whole road is gloomy wear
everything
the one slit of sunlight is coming
through the cloud onto the masjid
and it was it was oh it was the most
beautiful thing man
i'm just i'm just about to open it up to
subscribers only so now instead of
members anyone can ask questions so if
anyone does have any questions go for it
ask the brother any questions inshaallah
allah
and uh we'll try to blast through it
inshallah
all right
[Music]
what steps did you take in order to
learn how to pray brother rakim
so
youtube literally there's so many like
there's so many videos that i just
watched
it take i can't lie to you it takes uh
it takes time
it took me about a week to learn how to
properly properly pray and memorize
things but even if you're starting
enough like
my friend um back in my accommodation he
reverted the one i was talking about
earlier and what he does is he plays
like they're just thinking about prayers
like prayer guide and some guy will say
like you can read al-fatiha then we'll
say
like supernatural like he would say like
the steps and we're meant to say and
then he would just pray in time with it
because obviously he's starting off he
doesn't like he doesn't know any of the
you know servers or nothing so
you're right salaam are you from london
no that's not bro
are you from london
are you
me yeah you bro oh [ __ ] it's a
subscriber yeah i'm not bro that's you
bro
i'm talking yeah i'm from south london
south london okay
you should come you should come one time
inshallah
let's do it
all right what made you weaver in a
nutshell how could you answer because
there's a lot of questions for you uh
islam is the truth
so i'm gonna um what is the number one
thing you will ask for in jannah
inshallah
you see my family there what about what
about you manage to see my family though
yeah literally i just want to see my
loved ones make it bro
man honestly i'm having a hard time
thinking obviously i want to see my
loved ones and everyone there
may allah i mean
other than that like i just honestly bro
i literally just want to make it there
that's it i'll be happy
alhamdulillah brother ismail writes how
do you strengthen your iman in faith all
prophecies will happen
bro what do you mean they have happened
so what are you talking about man
they're done they're basically done
there's one or one maybe two left or in
the process of happening other than that
bro
literally like most of us
there's a there's majority of scholars
unanimously agree that majority of the
minor signs have happened if i'm correct
yeah i think most of them i think
there's only two opinions one is that
they've all passed all of them and the
other opinion is that they've all passed
and two are still happening which is the
european river and gold appearing there
into clickbait right here you know some
of the quran brother
yeah i
but you got to do it bro you got to do
it yo guys if you want to hear him
recite sora fatiha spam the comments
right now right i can't i actually can't
actually
oh yeah
you're probably with people right
say it again are you with people or what
no no
um
like button for that if you made it this
far comment down below
so we know who made it this far next
question what were your views on islam
before reverting may allah keep you
steadfast i mean i mean
you know due to like
me being surrounded by muslims it was
always good you know obviously
my parents because my parents are
surrounded by islam equals terrorist
islam equals 9 11. you know what i mean
so obviously i'm blessed to be
surrounded by people like
you know muslims muslim brothers muslim
sisters always talking to me about it
and stuff
so it's always it's ingrid it's been
good
the 100 lover writes brothers i quit my
job because of vr i did it because when
i tried it
evil i got sick so i left
wait have you guys tried vr
i've i've tried it in oculus yeah i
tried i tried i tried like crazy
bro it was crazy it is aside from the
headset like killing my head like bro
literally i get out and i'm like i'm
moving my hands and i'm like bro is this
real life like it is the most trippy
thing and in the vr bro it's kind of
like online people are anonymous you
don't know their name their face
anything about them they can say
whatever they can do whatever and it's
just
you know when when i took it off i was
like oh yeah this is reality
like bro i was i i was crazy
i know that feeling bro i pick up my
phone and i'm like what the hell is
happening
yo stay away from the metal risk kids
brother rakim what is your favorite chef
or you can even give one of
i don't even know their names
subhanallah bro anyone what about any
awesome youtuber that you recommend bro
you gotta save the two muslims bro i'm
not gonna lie to you
definitely not the three muslims
you know what like my number one dream
is like number one like i just want to
meet this person must be
because i know people that meet him and
apparently he's just a calmest guy like
he's just like
he just treats you like a friend like i
want to meet this guy so bad i'm gonna
inshallah bro maybe i'll meet him bro if
not in this life then the next
sister's all right so rakeem continue
having good conduct with your parents
and other sometimes actions speak louder
than words inshaallah they'll see how
sincere you are and will also open their
hearts to islam that's the thing bro you
don't realize it bro or maybe you do but
a lot of people don't
that we are walking talking ambassadors
of islam
everywhere we go
you know we decide what people in our
circle will perceive islam as
so why not leave them with something
good leave them better than you guys met
i know so many people wrote that were in
your shoes and when they revert it's
like the one thing when they're you know
let's say their relationship with their
mom was not tight it was not good
but they were like mom i love you too i
love islam too much to like burden my
relationship with you so i'm gonna you
know unite my relationship i'm gonna
join bridges with you and that made
their mother accept islam bro just the
fact that it's like that there's no ego
in that anymore you know it's like
something
oh i remembered my favorite shake is um
king brother you said you want to become
a half is how has reading and memorizing
been for you thus far
i'm not going to lie to you it's more
about the time and i start for a lot
obviously i should be focusing on them
because but because of
uni it's been like i'm not gonna say
quite hard it's been very hard because
of the uni work and everything but with
memorizing it it's not even that i
thought it was gonna be really hard to
memorize it like back up like
if you try if you really try you can
probably
bang out a decently sized surah in like
a day
probably okay right a day or two
but yeah that's not it's not being too
hard not being too hard
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah yeah just
but he addresses himself as
he looks chinese because my mom-in-law
is chinese i don't know if you were
spitting some bars right there or what
not subhanallah
um my brother's memorizing quran has
become very easy mobile applications
yeah
very underrated
all right
bro we got a question from brother syed
got any plans to go to umrah or hajj
bro um
one of my brothers
he's gonna go hajj with a lot of people
this guy out of noma out of nowhere hits
me
bro are you free march 6th to march 16th
um i'm like
i don't know i'm not sure why tell me
tell me he's like i'm gonna buy a ticket
for you to come hydrate me
for free that's what he said
alhamdulillah
i done something so stupid
i told all of my friends
every single one that i told people i
didn't even know my friends friends and
i was like bro i'm gonna go hide i was
so gassed
then
something comes up something unique
comes off and i can't go that nazi
nazis bro it's crazy
but insha allah in the future of me and
my wife inshallah me my kids i can bring
them to hajime
i'm scared about shaving my head though
i can't
that's the thing man we have so many
comments right now we've got all the
brothers saying fatiha all this is the
same father inshaallah all right next
who is your favorite
claudi
uh yeah like reciter
okay
very good very good they're talking
about the recitation alhamdulillah
all right who's most masha allah
listen this is your show bro this is
your show next time inshallah
okay okay
he said it clearly better than some
others that's the thing bro you we got
to give ourselves a little bit of credit
you know mashallah you were on point
with that
better than most people all right
do islamic quizzes guys it'll be fun to
also benefit us inshallah inshallah a
good idea for the future
you should do that i'll be heading to
this yeah yeah see how much we know all
right so what is the rakeem's
ethnic background i want to know this
bro
i'm not going to lie
this is like i'm happy with talking
about anything you want but except this
okay i thought yeah he pleased the fifth
sorry
no worries
i'm fired i'll message you i'll message
you
one time i was in malaysia this was
before i was a muslim when i heard the
adan i didn't even i didn't even know
about deardan i heard i sat down and i
was like this is beautiful
this is beautiful man i saw the
neighbors i was in malaysia i saw my
uncle's neighbors leave that house hold
up
that was beautiful man
brother anthony writes is there any
major question you still have about
islam oh i want to know this bro
off the top of my head right now no
okay but i i do have a lot of questions
about islam why is this blank right now
okay what was your most defining moment
as a muslim
yeah like something like just like your
iman booster or the light bulb moment or
just when everything clicked or
something
when i was giving my colleague tawa
and the next day he asked me how i can
take my shadow
that for me i was like
that's when it's that's when it kicked
in for me because i was like
because in my life
if you look into islam this much this
much
you will see the truth in it
it's just you've got to put that
ignorance you've got to put that
ego aside you've got to be like listen
let me look at this open mind
um if you come into it with like your
glass half full it's not going to work
bro you need to empty that cup go in
right away just like brother rakim is
saying and it's a rabbit hole bro if you
don't want to go this much like he's
saying and you still arrogant keep going
everything is going to make sense to you
inshallah
bro what sports do you play
i used to skate a lot um play football
here and there in uni
um i love tennis i love badminton
i'm rubbish but i love that
um
do you support a football team
yeah i do
i support tottenham because of hyung min
you don't watch people
in toronto
you don't know
[Music]
g
all right all right i'm a muslim woman
and we need good muslim husbands fathers
and brothers
everyone always got something to say
about everyone bro yeah
mm-hmm
all right next
easy memorizing i mean bro
yeah i love your podcast for real
watched y'all episode on music today
before sleeping one hour before watching
this thanks really hum the logos from
allah may like something from us
i mean i'm not gonna lie um
you know for ramadan i'm just gonna be
banging out your podcast
replacing
you know a great tip that i have when it
comes to music is actually um something
i think it was
i forget what scholar said it might have
been um
i forget his name but one scholar said
that
the love of music and the love of quran
cannot exist in the same heart so if you
increase in your omar hashem recitations
the quran if you truly love the way it
sounds i promise you instead of music
banging in your head it's going to be
quran all the time just play in your
head
it's better for me as well because when
i listen to the quran i'm feeling that
peace when i'm listening to music i
thought
you know i mean well actually it's not
the right way but i feel like agitated
but when i'm listening to the quran i
feel like this is where this is what i
should be doing this is what i should do
i think that's it for the q a bro
and we are approaching on time
alhamdulillah next time in sha allah and
can make it too it was a pleasure
speaking with you bro do you know a
brother by the name of yahyabusir
nah
nah okay yeah he is
all over tik tok bro he's blowing up is
his re recitation of the world he's a
close friend of ours bro so if you want
you can you know you can find him on
tick tock inshallah we've had an episode
and i know you know him bro
yeah yeah bro i'm going to screen record
this and send this to you bro but
let's see bro
well how'd you spell it
y-a-h-y-a
yeah
yeah
and then
no no and then b-u-i-s-i-r
i can't lie to you since you know my
tick tock has been elevated i haven't
really been on tick tock that much
okay subhanallah bro i recommend you
rakim and anyone watching this right now
check out our episode we made with
brother yahya it was like last year bro
sometime and we just talked about quran
bro and it was such a good iman booster
and ramy ourselves so i can only imagine
what it is for the viewers in sha allah
yeah inshallah yeah that episode didn't
go hard much although it was really
tough
i'm gonna binge watch these videos i
can't
do it bro let's do it
he's so well made
yeah
he's a good brother masha'allah
i mean
what's up
what's up
me
yeah
oh no no i wasn't gonna
any last questions anything you want to
tell the viewers any word of advice
anything i just want to say like bro
even this conversation we're having now
this back and forth like
a man
i
i actually needed this i needed this
conversation
i needed this conversation thank you so
much for this opportunity thank you so
much for that
and i just wanted to say that these
conversations that we're having bro i
genuinely hope that people that made it
this far understand that the community
aspect having people that are
like-minded such an iman booster bro if
you're by yourself you don't have muslim
friends and family and you're living
this double life it might be hard i get
it but surround yourself with more
muslims and if your brother if your
sister you know fine like men did
like-minded people people that are on
the huck you know you don't have to cut
off everyone from your old life that's
not what we're saying but just find some
more people that you relate to in terms
of ideology in terms of akida in terms
of deen and just watch how your iman
just goes tenfold inshallah
is
crazy man it's a blessing to be here
right now
i just want to say to the people if i've
been like sluggish i apologize like it's
like
[Music]
we got 247 viewers right now we gotta
have minimum 247 likes inshallah smash
the like button if you made it this far
and comment down below hashtag bring
back rakim for part two inshallah you
shall like yo everyone like can i just
take one after this i'll take your
numbers down they'll message me your
numbers yeah
i wanna talk to you a little more
yeah
[Music]
to all the viewers at home may allah
bless you guys immensely this has been
the realest podcast in the dunya the
three muslims with that
is